[Music]
so it's really terrific to be able to
welcome everybody to this event this is
the fourth annual symposium on hybrid
scholarship at Yale University we call
this event Beyond Boundaries this is the
fourth year in a row that this event has
been organized as part of the program of
the digital humanities laboratory here
at Yale University library and the
fourth year that it's been organized
almost single-handedly by Kathryn duros
whom I hope most of you in the room have
heard of if not met I'm Kathy is in a
new role here in the digital humanities
laboratory serving as the manager for
the digital humanities lab and it's
really due to her organization and her
vision that we've been able to do these
fourth year in a row of the Beyond
Boundaries symposium and really the move
moved to this part of the library
because those of you who've attended
before and know that we've been in a
lecture hall the move to this part of
the library and the connection with a
Frankie family of digital humanities lab
to my right is symbolic of a bigger
renovation a bigger shift in the library
physically and a really exciting suite
of new services that were offering in
the Frankie room to support digital
scholarship hybrid scholarship and the
digital humanities in a beautiful new
room through the generosity of the
Frankie family in conjunction with agoI
sueda foundation we're going to be
holding a our poster session at the end
of today's activities in the Frankie
room which I hope those of you in the
room have seen this before but if you
haven't it's a really terrific
opportunity to see the breadth and depth
of projects that we're highlighting in
the Frankie room right after our
roundtable discussion today as I
mentioned this is the fourth year we've
held Beyond Boundaries and we're doing
it in partnership not only with Yale
steam which is a group that is dedicated
to the intersection of stem and the arts
and humanities but also this year in a
new effort with code for good which is a
group on campus that is interested in
the social in
of code and programming we're really
excited to be able to partner with these
two student-focused organizations to
bring you beyond boundaries um we're
gonna just go right into our lightning
talks I think we have seven folks who
are going to be able to give us some
terrific insight into things they've
been working on these include efforts by
undergraduates and graduate students and
so without further ado it's I'd like to
ask Zhen to come up and to talk to us
about organizing without oppression
building democracies in the 21st century
[Applause]
and I am a senior in the stats and data
science department so I'd like to start
by asking a question how many of you
guys have heard of the singularity I see
a lot of hands going up and you might
think of it as a point where machine
intelligence and artificial intelligence
kind of rapidly improves and you know
maybe surpasses human intelligence you
might think of it as a synthesis of
perhaps human and machine where we work
in integrative systems you might think
of it as a robot apocalypse where the
machine just becomes really good at
making paper clips and something I think
scares at least me and fear maybe some
of you is that there's this question of
how do we make sure that the systems we
build actually do what we really want
them to not what we stay we want them to
but what we really mean how can machines
are made out of silicon and programming
languages ever comprehend what it means
to feel what it means what we value in
life how we live and act and how we
conduct ourselves with
fellow humans I think one problem here
is the issue of trust part of these
issues are do we have faith that the
machine that we build will in fact
satisfy these specifications as computer
scientists we might like to have some
kind of guarantee we might want to say
ok here are certain criteria that our
systems will satisfy we might want to
prove that for example these systems
can't go have up they can't for example
turn into a totalitarian regime now some
of the questions involved here might
seem pretty new for example autonomous
car systems have been around only for a
couple of times but as a matter of fact
these questions are actually really old
they've been some of the questions that
we've been thinking about for hundreds
if not thousands of years we've actually
had super intelligences for almost as
long as we've had civilization now what
do these super intelligent systems look
like I mean I don't see any AI here you
look like government's systems of law
maybe economies these organizations of
people and machines can do things that
none of us ever could they integrate
terabytes if not exabytes of information
every day shape the flow of information
and resources across the whole world and
sometimes do things that we wouldn't
really want or expect from our systems
things like war famine and other things
now the people who ask these kinds of
questions I'm actually sorry for the
yellow that might be hard to read Oh so
people who ask these kinds of questions
are generally regarded perhaps as
political theorists economist
philosophers artists and writers these
questions are do these systems actually
act from my best interest do they act in
the best interest
society and if we're in charge of
designing these systems as a society how
do we design them so that they have the
properties that we want how do we design
them so that they ensure for example
freedom and equality for everyone how do
we design these systems so that there
are safeguards in place so that if these
systems ever do fail we'd have some
assurance that they won't fail terribly
things that the founding fathers were
doing when they founded America when
they wrote down the Constitution things
that people do when they talk about
checks and balances things like taxation
or social goods now as part of this talk
I would like to share with you a vision
for our democracy and how this would
apply to us today a lot of democratic
theorists think that democracy in its
current form it's not fixed democracy is
in fact malleable is subject to change
and in a lot of different systems it
might not even look like what we think
of democracy as you think of it today
for example how many of you think that
voting is absolutely essential to
democracy how many of you think that
deliberation is absolutely essential can
we have one without the other
possibly not is one more important than
the other could we have different forms
of voting and these are questions that a
lot of people have explored in recent
years but also in years past and this
kind of comes at a time when democracy
is kind of hit by seemingly recent
forces for example the rise of faith
views political non-participation and
these criticisms of democracy are
something that we have to think about
both in terms of as as citizens what
what they mean to us but also in terms
of system designers how do we design new
systems so that these issues can be
perhaps mitigated I like to share with
you a few ideas that a lot of really
cool people have had for example one of
one of the
fasters the political science department
here Hal Atlanta more um has proposed an
idea of open democracy which is kind of
taking from the harbor Bosnian point of
view where you have systems of
deliberative discourse there are kind of
centered around exchanging ideas between
people so for example you might elect a
randomly selected body of citizens and
those citizens could deliberate in the
best interest of also discussed and if
there are a random sample perhaps they
want to kind of encapsulate the kinds of
interest that people in general have you
might also think about for example
systems like liquid democracy where you
would give your vote perhaps to someone
that you trust
so instead of everyone voting for a
state representative voting for
president you just give your vote to
someone and they could vote under behalf
on certain issues you may also think
about ideas about context and what kind
of forums we might need for democracy
for example would Facebook be a good
forum to you know discuss certain issues
and sure we found that you know like
Facebook has a lot of you know
interesting things with it and so with
technology comes a certain
responsibility but also a certain
opportunity so I like to share with you
some ideas for bringing these kinds of
theories into practice and giving giving
us a sense of where do we go from here
and how do you Minh and Technology
interact to form government systems so a
lot a lot of experiments on democracy
have been smaller scale they've revolved
around citizen participation very
specific issues and a lot of the
processes of government that we have
today are actually really effective
about what they do example think of the
city of New Haven or the United States
we have to kind of balance a lot of
different issues so one proposal is to
test new ideas of democracy by having a
virtual online platform and this
platform and actually kind of abstract
over core fundamental entities like
people and votes and give you a set of
primitives on which to build new
democracies so one experiment that I've
kind of been working on it's kind of
gathering a set of people to kind of
build the first version of this
democratic infrastructure in which you
would have a layer for our that forms a
foundation for building new kinds of
assemblies different forms of referenda
different forms of voting and making
that available to researchers to people
in a communities to kind of figure out
where that kind of technology would fit
and how it would work in our existing
government so our idea is to focus on
smaller scale municipal governments just
because it easier to work with people
you know in a local context and towns
are also kind of like big enough so that
you could you know have interesting
democratic experiments and you know it's
kind of the starting phases of this
research but we're kind of thinking
about you know kind of expanding it to
more people getting more people involved
in thinking about some of these issues
like what kind of values should we kind
of think about as we build out these
systems and yeah do we have any
questions then for being our first
speaker and we're actually going to hold
questions for the poster session in the
next room because I know that folks are
going to have all sorts of interesting
interactions with our speakers but thank
you so much for going first
[Applause]
while continuing the theme of other ways
of organization we have a talk next by
Francis Vega non-utilitarian utopias
Public Library's is key policy partners
for integration and skills training
programs thank you all for coming thank
you I would especially like to thank the
Frankie family digital humanities lab
staff for their ongoing support and
guidance in our research I feel like the
field of digital humanities is
particularly important today we're
experiencing what has been called a
fourth Industrial Revolution which is
marked by dramatic transportation
transport transformation in both the
technologies that impact our working
lives and the ethnographic changes that
are reshaping our communities in the
visualization tools that digital
humanities provides allow us to assess
and share these changes with others as
we will see in the conversations today
in the posters that will be presented
later
so I'm Francis Vega and I'm a political
science student here at Yale University
in my interests lie and social
integration and labor policy
particularly how programs related to
social integration and skills training
are coordinated and implemented at the
local and municipal level and it's
convenient that we are in a library
today because I am fascinated by these
institutions so here this image allows
us to see that all the all of
Connecticut's public libraries and
because of their branch systems public
libraries frequently have built-in
network characteristics which allow for
coordinated programming and the sharing
of best practices so bring us into New
Haven this compact image taken from the
New Haven free public libraries website
shows us that there are five public
libraries in the city and a bookmobile
it also allows us to look at Trent user
Tran
for the library and their services in
2018 and I'm not sure what your
perceptions of public libraries are but
they have been drastically changing so
they're adopting their services in in
programming to meet the very demands
posed by changes in social demographics
and labor needs the books are still
popular as we can see in this
infographic that there is a constant and
steady increase in Wi-Fi usage and
program attendance and these programs
range from storytimes for new parents to
coding courses for children to resume
workshops and more and these trends and
programs are consistent across developed
nations as well and I can share my
research from France the UK asked me
questions about libraries please and
here we see a selection of digital
courses offered for free on a monthly
basis right down the street at Ives
public library a key service offered by
public libraries is digital literacy
defined by the American Library
Association as a skill that quote
enables the individual to recognize when
information is needed and gives them the
ability to locate evaluate and use that
information more effectively and close
it's not enough to simply have access to
a smartphone or a computer in order to
stay in a truly democratic society all
members must be able to navigate
increasingly complex technologies much
as we are doing in this symposium on
digital humanities today great examples
of digital humidity digital literacy
here range from free classes on how to
assess and analyze everyday information
like the infographics and these
powerpoints to establishing professional
networks through LinkedIn this variety
of free training is impressive yet if we
look at the relationship between
government agencies and public library
networks we see a lack of coordination
this is Connecticut's - this is
Connecticut's two-on-one which is the
state
Estate site that is intended to serve as
a one-stop portal linking users to
essential services throughout the state
yet when I enter job training formats in
New Haven only one option came up as we
can see it's a pre-employment background
check site related searches linked to
agencies which often had barriers to
entry including age income and veteran
status the lack of coordination between
government agencies working with
integration and labor policy and
relevant public library programming is
not unique to the United States although
both the European Commission and the
OECD stressed the urgent need to provide
basic educational programming and
digital literacy trainings throughout
their member states the their policy
prescriptions rarely if ever mentioned
public knife library networks as
potential partners and if there are any
library librarians in the room
you know how extensive these networks
are all right so in addition to these
more tired targeted digital literacy
programming there are countless
opportunities to engage and diverse
social and cultural events in public
libraries such encounters can strengthen
community relationships and what can be
politically and economically fraught
times here we see examples of some of
these programs at libraries in New Haven
as well as an image of the newly
remodeled Ives squared space where a
mother were among other cool events
entrepreneurs can get advice on their
startups from external partners and
residential fellows earlier today in
fact there was a meet-up of game
developers where participants from all
ages and skill levels came together to
share advice and get support I would
definitely recommend if you hadn't been
to IDE square or been into the New Haven
Public Library since they were renovated
to go and check it out so I'll conclude
by pulling back to this overview of
public night library networks at the
state level and I'll ask that we
reconsider not only the density of these
institutions but also the reach of their
extended networks of patrons government
agents
and external partnerships how might
these connections better serve the needs
of contemporary societies and perhaps
more importantly what is your public
library up to right now thank you so
much I look forward to learning about
digital humanities research with you and
to answering any questions that you
might have thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks so much to Frances for that and
I'd like to call up for our next speaker
Kenny Liao who's gonna speak about
virtual politics a case study of Reddit
great thank you so much it's such a
pleasure to be with you guys today I'm
really excited about the work and that
Beyond Boundaries does I'm specifically
and my own statistics student whose
first love intellectual of really was
anthropology um I think there are
increasing worlds of Social Research
which necessitate and demand I'm a data
science approach and today's on research
that I'll be presenting from my senior
thesis and lends itself to that as well
um the idea I see data science said and
its intersection with anthropology is
this I'm specifically that um when we're
looking at online lives um how do we
listen to data um well it was
specifically with statistics and in
suits political life online especially
with platforms like red atlas
specifically because users are anonymous
and they're a geographical and so those
are approaches and words that aren't
often associated with ethnographic
research where you're necessarily part
of a community in a space with people
who have names
um and so statistics seems to be a much
more natural lens itself more naturally
to this way the research I'll be
presenting on today is really focusing
on this question what does the like mean
and what is a good political comment and
so this research focuses on the politics
subreddit which is a sub community
within Reddit focused on US politics
um analyzes data from 2008 to 2018 just
for a scale sense of scale understated
is about like a terabyte with across
which is all stored everything every
single post and comment on reddit is
stored online on google cloud and is
extremely accessible um cool let's see
so it's interesting because I feel like
a lot of social research focuses on
Facebook and Twitter and a DS don't seem
to lend themselves as easily to
statistical research because there's
privacy concerns whereas um reddit is
inherently a public website it's known
as the front page of the Internet and
surprisingly for a lot of people I don't
think they know that this was actually
the third most clicked upon website in
2018 just after Google went after
Facebook after Google and after YouTube
so before Twitter and Facebook
additionally in terms of engagement um
based on its population of users under
more web they're more clicks on RHIB
more clicks on reddit per user than any
other site so in terms of the richness
of engagement and richness of they read
it really seems to be a promising tool
um but there's something special about
um the politics sub community on reddit
specifically that with Reddit you um
each sub the subreddit has its own set
of rules and so here the unique thing
about politics is that users are only
allowed to post news articles
specifically um in their post the
headline must be identical to the news
at her website and the content must be a
link to the news article which means
that users can't impose anything else
and interpretation and political
commentary can only occur into comments
it's really interesting to look at the
distribution of some of the articles
here um I apologize for the lack of way
from going to a y-axis but what that
means is I use a topic model to assess
all of the news headlines that have been
posted on Reddit from 2008 to 2018 and
group them using topic modeling and then
using a walk track clustering algorithm
and to six main themes so the first one
reflects foreign policy um it's really
interesting that like it's kind of
stagnant until after 2016 what actually
happens is that Trump gets associated
with a lot of foreign policy because of
the Nuland investigation and because of
Russia and so those topics actually
change their meaning after 2016
um the graph number two indicates
popular issues um which remains
relatively static across all the time
the increase just um is an increase in
population I'll read it um let's see
number three is election issues which of
course um rise up in 2012 and 2016 but
particularly
for 2016 the bump in 2016 with number
four actually indicates campaign
corruption um which shows it bubbles up
in 2016 and it dies down again
and number five talks about economic
policy which is pretty stagnant overall
and so there's really cool topic
modeling things that you can do if the
whole subreddit and a lot of really
interesting topics come out as well so
you see the Keystone pipeline becoming
its own topic you see fire and fury
becoming its own topic middle
investigation becoming its own topic as
well it's a really really clean dataset
so the key question coming across um
here a particularly interesting rule
that the moderators have placed but they
can't enforce is that they want people
uses on politics to vote basically liked
or disliked comments based on the
quality and not the opinion of the
comment um you can't enforce it just
because likes are anonymous and because
there's a ton of them right um and so
it's interesting to see what actually
happens um which is the the focus of
this talk um this is an example of a
post one of the most popular posts of
all time which is done which on becoming
president
I'm from AP and the first comment says
I'm for them faithless electors from
Washington three Powell one spotted
eagle um
what's interesting about Reddit again is
that there is no personalization of
feeds and you can sub suck subscribe to
different communities but within the
community everyone sees exactly the same
thing in the same order both post wise
and comment wise and these are related
in the disorder is determined by the
popularity which is the likes and the
down votes of each comment and so here
we can if you're interested you can
transfer every single post into a tree
like structure where I'm because you can
have comments comments to comments asset
or you can build out and what long
humming chains are and how users irons
it but here's the experiment um if we're
thinking about what makes a comment
successful or what makes people like a
certain comment um I framed it in terms
of this hypothesis I'm running a
classifier to see where a model using
just generic generic variable
so for example how popular the pulse was
where it came from the news article and
winner was posted I'm comparing that
with specific language features which
one is more predictive um the idea is
that if language features can actually
help prediction we can also detect which
language specific which language fidgets
actually lead to a comment being
associated with a higher higher score
lower score um and so I run this with
logistic regression basically what that
happens is it's classifying comments
into either popular comments or
unpopular or not popular comments um
where popular comments is defined as
ones who make the top three the top
three most liked comments or both I'm on
that post this if you're interested the
language features come from a program
called Li WC or linguistic in Korean
word count which is a status
state-of-the-art psychometric um
language analysis tool labels on
comments or any sort of text with
positive and negative emotions but also
um things like how an analytical is how
much powers use um authenticity
emotional tone and so these are a lot of
interesting and richer variables coming
from psychological literature that we
can easily label our text with I analyze
my data on 2012 2016 and 2018 data but
just here are some of the brief results
um you'd expect fifty percent to be like
just a random prediction of whether a
comment is successful or not um and we
achieve about 70 percent accuracy with
both the baseline and with the language
vision model um there's no significant
difference between the baseline ethnic
language virtual model um
precision and recall what that means
precision is if I label a communist
being in the top three how many of them
are truly in the top three and but we
get about two-thirds accuracy on that
and recall is of all of the top three
comments how many do I actually pick up
as correct um and I get about an 80%
accuracy on that and so it performs much
better than chance but there's a little
few more parameters that we can tweak
that I'll do later on that are
interesting
um in terms of predictive models um here
are some of the language features that
the model picks up on and so we see that
comments which are analytical um and
emotional
tend to lend lend themselves towards
high popularity the contrast there is
interesting but then we can also look at
more sophisticated words words with long
longer words and words in dictionaries
and things using uh numbers are also
more predictive overcoming being
successful and interestingly I'm using
more generic adjectives and using
informal speech um associates itself
with not being successful just for those
of you who are interested in topic
modeling um this is the next kind of
step in the process which is if we've
associated each post an article with a
theme or a topic then after that we can
really go and see how language features
vary vary with each topic so for example
our posts which have to do with
economics more more favorable if they're
more quantitative whereas ylim if it's
more about like political scandals do
they lend himself towards more emotion
and so that's possible with the mixed
effects model am going to explore later
on but yeah thank you for listening to
the talk thanks so much to kenny'll for
that and i'd like to invite up Lisa I'm
sorry Tyler Lutz who is going to be
speaking to us on science in fiction
modern physics as mirror and views
thank you in conjecture is on world
literature Franco Moretti articulates a
conception of literature as the
composite product of endogenous
phylogenetic literary developments of a
given language or tradition and waves of
exogenous foreign forms that continually
Buffett and modulate them to read world
literature and Ready's account is to
read with a sufficient distance from the
text that these global waves
developments like the novel or stream of
consciousness come into focus
pre-empting the criticism that any such
world literary critical project might
undermine the coherence of national
literature's Moretti owns that quote
there is no other justification for the
study of world literature but this to be
a thorn in the side a permanent
intellectual challenge to national
literature's my project takes as its
original motive the question what is
world literature's thorin and decide or
to put it in other words why stop at
planetary boundaries the dizzying
expanses of intergalactic space the
humming nonsense propounded inscrutably
small scales and the coordinated chaos
of global climactic formations are all
as much sites of cultural production as
any national literature all domains of
human experience that we each partaken
where do they fit in Moretti's tiny tidy
scheme of interconnected
ethno-linguistic polities quite long in
richard jean sori stylization of
Moretti's global waves as turbulent flow
takes a crucial step towards
highlighting that the very figure under
girding Reddy's world literature is
itself a borrowed foreign form these are
meso scale Eddie's in the ocean compiled
by NASA it's only through the combined
cultural production of inter woven
networks not only of economic historians
that Moretti high weights but also
cartographers archeologists astronauts
and planetary scientists of all stripes
that we can even begin to visualize the
patterns of global circulation that are
a precondition for world literature and
not only our world and national
literature's but two nodes in a vast
assemblage of inert interlinked
intellectual projects it also becomes
difficult to describe any kind of
hierarchy to them the closer we look
even at ostensibly hyperlocal forums
let's zoom in on one of these waves the
more we realized that the local
materials
that Moretti is imagining are themselves
subject to cycles of global circulation
this is a artwork by Chris Jordan made
up of 2.4 million pieces of plastic
that's equivalent to the amount of
plastic that we put in the ocean every
hour you could argue this is a this is a
bit of a contrived example but let me
remind you that the very English
language that I'm using right now is
nothing more than the accreted flotsam
of many different languages so I
wouldn't take this very seriously as a
model for literature itself and if
you'll if you'll squint at it just a
little bit we can actually see something
that looks a lot like literature this is
to borrow from Kenya's topic modeling
this is a topic model of a corpus of
fictional texts taken from haughty trust
this represents 1920 to 1922 what we're
seeing here every bubble represents a
cluster of words the their groups here
according to their likely the likelihood
of their cohort co-occurrence in
different texts within the corpus and we
can see some kind of recognizable
features here here one of these topics
looks like a kind of courtly fiction
upon King thou shalt this might be
something more like a Western camps
trails or some rivers some Indians and
here's a gender domestic space it's not
entirely obvious what these topics are
supposed to represent though can we call
them genres are they somehow micro
discourses little subsets of the
language what I want to argue is that
what this topic model is showing us
actually is literature resolved very
literally into its constitutive
hermeneutics circles domains in which
form and material are mutually Co
determining in other words the closer we
look at world literature the closer we
find that we end up right back where we
started at these turbulent Eddie's I'm
thinking of world literature is a kind
of fractal pattern there's a subset of
these Eddie's that I'm actually somewhat
qualified to talk about as a physicist
words like this entropy as a word
entropy was invented in 1980 by Klaus
eosin Germany I'm playing with two
different spellings here to account for
the difference in the languages I kids
reinvented in 1950
by Shannon and information theoretic
context and ever since then it's kind of
been percolating into these different
national literature's but true to my
argument I think I want to think of lit
of entropy as more than just a word do
the magic of the second law of
thermodynamics it contains within it an
entire narrative and miniature it goes
like this stuff breaks we could even
think of entropy as designating a kind
of micro Jehan room what I hope to do
with my work is to contribute a small
amount to the project that we might as
well call cosmic literature by
investigating how physics as a
collection of words and stories that are
continually folding back into each other
how that physics both informs and it's
shaped by the material constituents and
formal determinants of literature one
place to start is to disaggregate one of
you I'm going to take the English
literature's in the bottom two rows here
and just aggregate them by genre here's
a time series of how entropy shows up in
my corpus this is not something I would
have expected
apparently poets are a lot more
interested in entropy than our
dramatists and fiction writers if we
poke around a bit more we can find other
words that show a similar shape here's
centrifugal centripetal also has a
similar shape so it is disorder and we
can go on and on like this chaos seems
to be something that that poetry is very
interested in
I want to argue that's a mistake though
I don't either want to say that that
poetry is somehow an inherently chaotic
disordered dizzy medium nor don't want
to say that physics has somehow been
pushing it in that direction my working
hypothesis is that both poetic and
natural scientific depictions of things
like disorder and chaos form a closed
loop each Rama fiying each other through
a diversity of different channels and
just so you don't go away thinking
poetry is the only one getting in the
action here here's the similar shape
different word but now I actually draw a
drama seems a lot more interested in
quantum than either poetry or fiction
likewise with galaxy I don't know what
to say about these things I don't I
don't know how to interpret them what I
do as a scientist I want to cast a
certain amount of shade on them these
are averages of course
as we know are affected by extreme
events what we really want to do is take
a time slice in these and ask ourselves
for every point on here what is the
distribution of texts the average of
which is shown here
so here I've done that for you I'm
looking at a different word now this is
temperature in fiction in the same time
period the x-axis here is plotting the
normalized word occurrence in a text
word frequency and the y-axis is showing
how many texts talk about temperature at
that frequency this is a log-log plot
and it looks quite a lot like a power
law that's super cool again I don't I
don't know what this means
I also know it's not tremendously
surprising power laws show up all over
computational linguistics but it's
useful for something by measuring the
slope of this line we get the exponent
in the power in other words we get in a
certain sense how how quickly interests
in these in these in these words falls
off as as a function of the corpus and
we can do this with different words as
well here I'm looking at the word
infinite you could try in poetry drama
fiction of course we can do this through
time these are no longer fits now now am
i power law hypothesis is kind of
following apart maybe it might work for
poetry for drama it's a bit more
complicated but that in itself is an
interesting point as a physicist you
might want to call this something like a
power spectrum and it's interesting ask
where'd words enter these genres are
they coming in are they just percolating
in through general usage in which case
we might expect something like this the
fictional case where they're they're
showing up in the general language and
they're sort of moving into the texts in
a more concentrated fashion or do they
show up maybe already like in the genre
in the drama case here do they just pop
in as concentrated bursts that then
flatten out as time goes on so that's
just a snapshot of some of the questions
that I'm interested in I thank you for
your attention I'm very eager to hear
your thoughts
[Applause]
thanks so much to Tyler and could now
invite Alisa up to speak about lived
experience as a theory of innovation
hi everyone I'm Lisa a junior studying
economics and I'm also in the human
rights program and this year I've been
working at SCI city as part of the
knowledge equity team to study some
questions that I want to present to you
here all today so to start off with this
is AI keas refugee shelter and it was
designed at the height of the refugee
crisis bringing together a Kias approach
of easy construction and easy assembly
to the massive need of for housing for
the millions of refugees coming from the
Syrian civil war and other global
conflicts so naturally this shelter won
numerous awards it was praised for being
easy to assemble with no tools necessary
for being more durable for being
stab-proof and more yet when the refugee
shelter was actually deployed it became
quickly apparent that it was not all
that was chalked up to be so some of the
complaints about the shelter meager
limited lack of use of local materials
no insulation lack of natural light how
can it be that a shelter that won so
many awards for changing people's lives
actually had all these issues and I'm
sure that the designers did their
research but it's clear to me that true
a true understanding of the whole
spectrum of local needs was not at the
center of this design so why then with
this refugee shelter received so many
awards when a refugee shelter like this
one crafted ingeniously out of scavenged
materials by refugees themselves is not
applauded as similarly innovative why is
it that innovation that derives from
lived experience from actually being a
refugee is not receiving awards why is
it that learned expertise has a monopoly
that learned expertise is the only
expertise and that professionals are the
only experts naturally this is hardly
limited to the International Development
space I think too often especially in
the social sector those in power do not
have lived experience with the issues at
hand and so I want to study why is that
and this semester as part of the
knowledge equity initiative at SCI City
I've been studying some of the
philosophy behind AI to see what it can
reveal about the nature of knowledge and
specifically I've used AI as a foil to
study how human brains value lived
experience so first AI naturally is art
is intelligence exhibited by a computer
as opposed to a human or a living being
and obviously AI does not have to be
oriented around human intelligence or
replicating human intelligence but
that's the approach I'm taking so
fundamentally there are two components
of AI data and algorithms we can think
of data as a noun and algorithms as a
verb data represents characteristics
within our world from personal data
which are markers of our lives who group
data to machine based data algorithms
are the mechanisms by which these
characteristics are transformed into
something useful and more often than not
that something useful as a decision but
can also be patterns that help make
decisions and heuristics as well for us
as humans we might think of algorithms
within our brains as wisdom or knowledge
one of the biggest debates in artificial
intelligence is algorithms versus data
which is more important for AI well we
might see better algorithms as better
reasoning skills and better critical
thinking skills and for humans the
equivalent of more data might be more
conversations had or more experiences of
course these two are intimately related
having more conversations for example
leads not only to a broader pool of data
points on which our brains can draw upon
but also might improve our critical
thinking skills but it also it is also
important to point out that data and
algorithms are not the same thing
a lack of good data is not going to be
fully compensated by a good algorithm
and a plethora of data will not
compensate for a poor algorithm so
another question to think about is
whether more data is always going to
produce more better decisions and that's
not necessarily true more data can add
noise but what is true and I'm quoting
the core data science team head here is
that better data is always better so
data that is related to the issue that
we're studying
so given this framework where does
lived-experience fit in well we can
think of lived experience as having
characteristics of both data and
algorithms it's not data represented in
numbers which is how many of us are used
to thinking of data but it's data as a
record of our experiences and lived
experience as data is better data
because it's related to the issues that
we are studying lived experiences also
like algorithms and that it influences
the lens through which we process
information so given all of this I think
what the artificial intelligence model
tells us is that if
the output of our brains is the product
at the inputs and reasoning skills then
the ideas we are able to generate are
directly related to the experiences
we've had that's learned expertise will
not have the same realm of possible
ideas as lived expertise and vice-versa
so an example to bring us back to the
refugee shelters someone who is
experienced in security of statelessness
is going to have an understanding of
what it means to be a refugee and what
refugee needs are that is not replicated
by someone who doesn't have that same
lived experience and so the creativity
and innovation that lived-experience
generates is fundamentally different
from someone who is a professional in
the international development space
while a master's degree in international
development might provide an algorithm
with which we can think about in
statelessness and insecurity that is
never going to replace the lack of true
understanding of what it means to be a
refugee and the innovation that derives
from that lived experience what all this
is to say is that lived experience is
innovation that our realm of
possibilities is fundamentally related
to the experiences that we've had and
it's also not to say that it's lived
expert experience versus learned
experience but rather that each of us
has a unique combination of lived and
learned experiences that influence our
ideas and our creativity we just need to
be better about recognizing this fact so
then how did our bias against learned
expertise develop we'll also based on
our own experiences for a variety of
reasons the world we live in values the
professional but this doesn't mean that
lived experience is fundamentally less
useful it just means that we have
socially constructed the meaning around
lived experience so finally I want to
conclude with a hopeful example of how
valuing lived experience can improve our
world and also see lived experience as a
theory of innovation so this is Pigeon
Li a company founded to facilitate
communications between inmates and their
loved ones obviously family connection
and communication is a crucial support
system for rebuilding lives after prison
and that was a crucial point recognized
not by someone who's never been to
prison but by a former prisoner himself
so Frederick Hudson and M Nate founded
this company after his experience in
prison and he used that experience to
found him as the root of his innovation
his understanding of how communication
and
work combined with his lived express his
learned experience participating in an
accelerator is what allowed this idea to
flourish so in conclusion I think this
conference is all about breaking
boundaries but I also hope how we can
build bridges and see how AI can help us
value lived experience as a theory of
innovation
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks so much to Lisa for that and now
I'd like to call up our final speaker
Mary will be talking to us about
generative and variational choreography
via machine learning
so this work started with a question can
I use my technical background to extend
my choreographic practice and create new
work that still feels like my own or to
quote my hero postmodern choreographer
Pina Bausch how can i well she said I
didn't want to in it to imitate anybody
any movement I knew I didn't want to use
and so to me that means how do I get out
of my own head and my own body while
still remaining in my body in creating
new work using this tool and what I
would say is this not only requires
freshness and novelty because at the
extreme of freshness and novelty it
could be abstraction or something that
isn't meaningful or is alienating to an
audience but it's also dangerous to stay
within a comfort zone of something that
feels authentic because sometimes that
can just be read as trite or not
generalizable to an audience so what I'm
interested in is this intersection of
freshness and novelty and authenticity
and in Pina Bausch this case I think
this often they should be a video this
often creates really fascinating results
in choreographies so what I chose to
embark on is this adventure to combine
machine learning to generate
choreography in some interesting ways I
thought that as a as a scientist I might
have something unique to contribute to
this conversation as well as a
choreographer talking about lived
experiences and how this can be useful
so this is not me alone although I
started on my own I quickly found out
that collaboration is one of the best
ways to advance your project so I'm in
the physics department here as PhD
student in particle physics and so I've
joined up with my collaborator chase
who's a postdoc in the physics
department as well with Doug who is
established here as well as my colleague
Illya
and researcher in his own right some VR
and ma are artists and some new dancers
who have been thrown into the mix so a
really interesting group of people in
the room at once my data collection
started at the C cam the Center for
collaborative Arts and Media this is in
their new motion capture studio and I've
highlighted these motion capture cameras
within the room there are 20 in total
and so I suited up with these very
reflective sensors on my body so overall
the data set that I was analyzing was a
series of about 55 points on my body in
three full dimensions with very few gaps
in the data at a pretty high frame rate
for a pretty extended period of time
this is me dancing in the space so we
didn't throw machine learning at this
problem arbitrarily machine learning has
been shown to be a really effective tool
for understanding very complex and
nonlinear datasets that was proven back
in the 90s to show that we can use
machine learning to approximate any
continuous and bounded function within
certain limits with with some caveats to
that but in general we approach neural
networks because they are at this
incredibly powerful tool for
approximating very complicated functions
and this is a bummer that these videos
aren't showing but let me see if I can
try this this way is connected to Wi-Fi
right
okay um yeah I don't know I don't know
what to do about this but um I can well
I can illustrate and describe but
basically I would say that um something
that I have also found interesting about
my exploration neural networks is that
they are choreographic in themselves the
training of a neural network involves
directing your the movement of various
elements of your neural network itself
through this landscape this higher
dimensional or lower dimensional
landscape that represents the error
inherent in your model at any one point
in time so by so by directing our model
in its learning it's yes great cool so
so this sort of represents this
trajectory through space represents this
higher dimensional or maybe an abstract
representation of my model at any one
point in time I'm trying to give it the
right instructions to get to a minimum
of one of these points so you can see
that this model is sort of moving
towards a minimum so I want to minimize
my error overall in my model and so this
is a sense of choreography in itself of
figuring out the right right ways to
direct this model and so I wanted to
emphasize this because I I already know
of choreographic research as very
rigorous research in its own right so I
didn't want to approach this problem as
a sense of elevating choreographic work
through a lens of technology so in a
sense I'm seeing this from the
perspective as a deep dive into machine
learning research with an interesting
and meaningful data set as well as
perhaps enhancing my choreographic
research through an extended body or an
extended choreographic mind and I want
to highlight three areas of this
research that that this work has evolved
into preservation variation and
invention by preservation I mean a sort
of physicalized choreographic brain and
for me that has a lot of meaning that I
don't have time to get into but I'll
sketch out that
to me movement is a part of my identity
and I don't have a strong way of
preserving that for my own life and so
this this idea of preserving someone's
style like for me people have often said
that's something about my movement
reminds them of my mom so there's this
sense of what does it mean to preserve
human when style and movement is
important to your own identity and also
for myself to retain the potential to
invent with my current choreographic
body or maybe future iterations of my
choreographic body at any point in time
so I find that very fascinating and so
this literally can represent the actual
data of motion capture of myself
improving in the studio which is
compelling in its own right but I hope
to extend that by also physical izing
the potential of my body to choreograph
so not only a record but a kind of
limitless model that can constantly
generate me work now I wanted to show
what that looks like when that model is
not trained very well just to give you
guys a sense that it's very difficult to
capture a human body moving it's a
complicated problem and I am NOT
imposing any constraints into this model
about what a human should look like and
so I hope that gives some context for
some of the exciting results that we
were able to achieve later
where we are able to generate arbitrary
like sequences movement that really do
feel authentic we like myself because it
is derived from my own data now not only
are we interested in preservation we're
interested in variation so preservation
might be looking only towards future
results a variation is rather looking
inward trying to understand something
deeper about what my choreography
represents and so to me that has
represented projecting this complicated
dimensional data set into a reduced
dimensional data set to understand some
basic features about how it operates as
a dancer this is also interesting
because to me it's stripping the body
away from the choreographic work and
focusing in on some kind of innate idea
that is not disturbed by the body and
never imperfections it might have and it
also allows me to explore related
movements to input datasets that I've
already included so this is great for a
rehearsal studio this idea of sort of
riffing off of a choreographic idea many
times so this is one example of how we
can look at choreography in an abstract
way this is using principle component
analysis and what this does is it it
this plot shows a bit of my choreography
over time but of course it doesn't look
like choreography I can peer into this
model at various points so what I've
Illustrated here are two points that are
separate in time in the sequences that
have been somehow grouped together by
this model you can see that the model is
capturing something that feels real or
intrinsic about the choreographic idea
is something about moving upwards for
example or me crawling on all fours so
so there are some ideas that are grouped
in the meaningful way we also have more
powerful ways of reducing the
dimensionality of this data set PCA is
actually a fairly simple way of looking
at data because it is linear
now machine learning gives us nonlinear
learning capabilities so what we ended
up using was what we call an auto
encoder which can represent a lower
dimensional representation of this work
in a nonlinear complicated way here are
some examples of this abstract
dimensional version of my work this
represents a variation on a reference
sequence a and so reference sequence B
here is somehow found by this model to
be highly related but somehow different
and also completely generated in a sense
so I'll flash some quick examples of
variation so here what this represents
the the red person is is close to real
data whereas the colorful person is a
generated variation and what's
interesting about this is that it's able
to maintain a similar sense of rhythm
and style and yet it somehow feels
completely fresh and it's giving its own
kind of perspective on this idea so in
some cases we see that
it adds spins or rotations sometimes it
removes spins and rotations or this is
my favorite example translates a kick
into an upward movement in the arms so
there's a sense of upward miss as an
idea it translated into a different part
of the body and finally invention
breaking new choreographic ground that I
otherwise didn't have access to without
this technology this allows us to
explore new areas of my choreographic
Laden space that I as a human have not
been able to force myself to access
through whatever games or choreographic
constraints I want to use so here I'm
going to show some generated sequences
from my choreographic Leighton space
that the model has has constructed for
me
they're quite short so I'll flash
through some of them but you can see
that they look like a person and to me
it feels like me but they're completely
invented and and finally I would say
this has just been the start of some of
our play in our research there's a lot
of data to be scraped also from video
performances and so I've shown an
example of this on myself in a rehearsal
studio what this allows me to do is to
take choreographers or dancers who I
couldn't put into the Yale SECAM motion
capture studio and instead look at
videos of their performances and analyze
their movements in that way so I can
imagine sampling from a combination of
many choreographers Leighton spaces at
once we're also interested in
translating motion from between bodies
and also analyzing duets and partner
work to imagine generating a partner
given an input sequence of a single
mover and so on and so on research
doesn't have an end so thank you
[Applause]
well thank you Muriel and thanks to all
of our presenters if I could just ask
for a round of applause for the
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]